Thomas Pesquet est resté confiné pendant 6 mois
à bord de la Station spatiale internationale.
Il y retourne à la fin de l’année 2021.
Mais comment la fusée qui l’emmène
s’arrache-t-elle du sol ?
Comme un ballon de baudruche qui s’envole.
L’air qui s’échappe génère une force dirigée vers le bas.
Par réaction, une force identique
s’exerce dans la direction opposée.
Action/réaction et le ballon s’envole.
Une fusée n’expulse pas de l’air
mais une masse importante de gaz
issus de la combustion et très rapidement.
L’échappement génère une force dirigée vers le bas.
Par réaction, une force identique
est générée vers le haut.
Une force qu’on appelle la poussée.
Pour revenir , Thomas Pesquet utilisera
une « capsule… de déconfiné »
Si vous avez aimé cette capsule,
n’hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
Vous pouvez également voir ou revoir celles des jours précédents en cliquant sur le côté gauche.
J’en réalise un nouvelle par jour.
Et pour être sûr de n’en louper aucune,
abonnez-vous et activez la cloche.
Allez à demain et n’oubliez pas :
nous sommes toujours confinés mais on reste en lien.